well I think it's difficult for us to
get that if we are listening to the
media because unfortunately in the field
of energy it's actually one of the one
of the fields there several I'm sure
that don't lend themselves to sound
bites and one of the difficulties that
the energy industry hasn't telling its
story is that very fact is that it's
very it's very easy to tell people why
you should not have extractive
industries it's very difficult to tell
them why you need them we have built an
economy for better or worse for over 100
years that's based on highly extractive
industries and none of those are
completely environmentally friendly but
all the alternatives that we have been
talking about I think have absolutely
the same kinds of failings and that's
what very few people realize I don't
know how many of your observers have
actually seen when firms we talk about
how wonderful they are but we happen to
have a fair amount of them in the West
in particular I live in Texas which has
become kind of a hot area for West Texas
and Oklahoma and their god-awful sites
for the most part and they cover huge
amounts of acreage and we know they kill
birds we know in other ways they're very
good and wonderful but we almost lost
the electric power system in Texas
because the wind went from you know a
factor of 500 down to a factor of 1
because the wind stops oh no electricity
was being generated it's not an easily
storable form of energy so what we first
have to do is back up and say what do we
want from energy and what do we think we
can actually get from energy and the
problem is that we all say we want
alternative fuels but none of us can
actually get that it's nice to want
fusion but we haven't figured out a way
to create fusion it's wonderful to bring
the sun's power directly into our homes
but we haven't figured out a way to do
that economically as well and what is
missing oftentimes amongst all the
rhetoric is an actual week anomic lesson
what is it you want and what does it
cost you to get there there's a lot of
rhetoric around global warming there's a
lot of rhetoric around oil gas coal etc
my assumption is in the in the most
energy consuming economy in
world because it is the biggest economy
in the world by a long shot in the
United States of America is that people
have to start understanding that when
you turn on that electric switch you
know fifty percent of it's coming from
coal another twenty percent coming from
nuclear another twenty percent coming
from natural gas and the rest is coming
from hydro for the most part in very
little from alternative fuels when we
all love to have it come from some clean
renewable energy source absolutely when
is that going to happen not in my
lifetime and probably not in yours
either now does it mean we shouldn't be
doing things about it not at all we
should we absolutely have to but when I
could sit down with the department of
energy secretary and ask him how much
money you could really spend on new
research for alternate fuels and he
tells me we're spending 250 this is
several years ago we can maybe spend
another 250 wisely before it became
really marginal in terms of returns that
means we can't spend 18 billion dollars
which is what some of your congressmen
are telling you can be done that they'd
like to actually go and have all of us
subsidize 18 billion dollars worth of
alternative fuels that's not science
leading our energy solution that's
actually politics leading our energy
solution I guess I'm old enough to
realize that when federal government
says they're here to help you it
generally doesn't work out well in a
great classic example that is and this
is only because it matters to every
generation that follows mine is
corn-based ethanol it held a lot of
caucus votes during the recent run-up to
the elections right we thought it was
some kind of wonderful fuel it turns out
it's every bit as polluting in terms any
other natural form of gasoline it's much
less efficient it's driven record prices
for for food and for for livestock that
depends on that food and it's a horrible
answer it's at it's arguably best energy
neutral maybe twenty percent positive
maybe twenty percent negative it's a
horrible answer in yet our government
yours and my government is also slapping
an import fuel tax on sugar based cane
sugar cane based ethanol from Brazil now
if ethanol is good sugar cane is three
times as good as corn from an energy
production standpoint but it happens to
come from Brazil and we happen to want
to help our farmers in
people that are the adms the world
building these ethanol machines it's not
a good answer for America it from an
environmental perspective from an energy
perspective from a water perspective
what nobody talks about we all talk
about co2 we've got to start talking
about water which is a much more
precious resource than co2 and the other
thing is we got to get away from New
York Times get away from CNN being our
only source of information for real
science is we have to delve into
somebody's things get ahold the
Department of Energy's recent report and
energy that tells all of us that by 2030
best guess no matter what the heck we do
we need twenty-five percent more
conventional fuels what that tells me is
as you're building towards the future
don't forget the short term because at
the end of the day you're gonna be
paying three times as much for gasoline
if we forget the short term so instead
of doing economics 101 our legislators
would like us to actually create a
situation where you actually are
restricting conventional fuels while
you're building towards the future so
you're kind of at a black hole global
warming is a serious issue co2 emissions
by man-made sources are can't possibly
be good all of us have to do everything
we can we've got to start talking more
about conservation how many times do you
and I walk out of a hotel room without
turning off all lights I for the last
year and a half I've done that every
time I go out of a hotel room I do the
same at my house it's when oil started
approaching 70 dollars and I said I got
to start being more efficient but we
don't talk about stuff like that that's
a horrible waste of energy that's the
quickest and easiest way to actually
balance energy supply and demand but
then let's get after on all fronts make
sure that we get all diversified so we
don't bet on any one fuel as being the
some sort of Nirvana or silver bullet
because there isn't one it's going to
take us 50 years to get to a place where
we're going to be happy with the
solution and then we'll figure out a way
to grow energy usage even more but we're
actually reversing human history by
taking much more intense fuels that can
actually generate more energy from
smaller volume and actually going the
other direction where they're widely
collected and widely distributed with
things like corn based ethanol it makes
no sense